[Music]
it looks like a very serious event but
we'll find out when they look at the
documents I think people are going to
see a lot of bad things happen I hope
it's not so because if it is there's
never been anything like it in the
history of our country this was a
terrible situation what we're doing is
we're cleaning everything up it's so
important what I'm doing is a service to
this country we now call it Spygate
you'll calling it Spygate a lot of bad
things have happened welcome back to
this special edition of Hannity that was
President Trump earlier this week going
on offense against the deep state and
the president didn't stop there
he wrote on Twitter today quote the
Democrats are now alluding to the
concept that having an informant placed
in an opposing party's campaign is
different than having a spy as illegal
as that may be but what about an
informant who was paid a fortune and who
sets up way earlier than the Russian
hoax the president then wrote quote can
anyone even imagine having spies place
in a competing campaign by the people
and party in absolute power for the sole
purpose of political advantage and gain
and to think that the party in question
even with the expenditure of far more
money lost the president's comments are
causing people like former CIA director
John Brennan to lash out take a look
what's the difference between an
informant and a spy well first of all I
think is very typical of mr. Trump to
mischaracterize he's a master of
mischaracterization and dishonesty but
again this is something that mr. Trump
is as you said masterful out in terms of
twisting the truth in order to support
his narrative a lot of people are
complaining that the FBI and the CIA and
others didn't do enough to try to
uncover what Russia was doing well this
is exactly what the FBI was supposed to
do and thank goodness they did it
joining us now with reaction is the
author of the upcoming book the Russia
hoax Fox News legal analyst Gregg
Jarrett Judicial Watch president tom
Fitton and Washington Times columnist
and Fox News contributor Charlie hurt
all right Greg I'm going to start
with you did the FBI have a legal basis
to start a criminal investigation did
they even have a sufficient intelligence
basis to launch an intelligence probe
they had neither and the evidence is
abundantly clear and yet they launched
this dilating investigation into
then-candidate Trump they continued it
with President Trump and so the
president is rightly outraged and I'm
happy he's expressing it that they
essentially used a spy to infiltrate his
campaign to elicit and induce and entrap
people into saying incriminating things
if it was done for purely political
reasons and it appears it was that is a
crime it's called abuse of power
deprivation of rights under color of law
they were depriving candidate Trump of
his constitutional rights his right to
privacy and Fourth Amendment rights okay
Tom fit and I'm gonna go to you you know
there's a lot of talk about an informant
and a spy what is the difference between
an informant and a spy if there is one
at all there is no practical difference
that's gamesmanship on the part of the
Obama administration the top leadership
which this week was forced to admit they
did have someone targeting the Trump
campaign and was on the payroll of at
least one agency we don't know maybe
more than one agency would which would
have been without precedent within at
least in modern American history you'd
have to go back to the 60s to find
anything similar in terms of
governmental abuse and when you hear
clapper and Brennan and Comey and the
rest complained and criticized President
Trump for highlighting their corruption
you're looking at a list of people who
have in my view significant criminal and
civil liability over what went on on
their watch during the Obama
administration and after and and you
know and when you hear Brennan go crazy
and attack Trump like he is you have to
wonder why on earth that this why what
on earth was he ever allowed near any
counterintelligence investigation
related to mr. Trump
he obviously hated him and it explains
why things went off the rails they did
under the Obama administration
you know Charlie when when Tom says they
obviously hated Donald Trump I don't
think that it could be any clearer
you had a whole cabal at the top of the
FBI and in the intelligence community
there who hated Donald Trump and yet a
year ago when Devin newness and when it
appeared that you know there was
something cookin here and they thought
that you know the president was wearing
a tinfoil hat and Devin eNOS is off his
rocker you know it's all coming to
fruition oh it really is I mean remember
everybody thought that Devin Nunez was
he was it behaving bizarrely and he was
meeting with intelligence officials in
various secure locations at the White
House grounds and all of the press was
making fun of him and what we're seeing
today is that basically ever all of the
concerns that he sort of hinted that
back then a year ago over a year ago
have come to fruition and as as Tom
pointed out even you know even the
Democrats are having to acknowledge that
yes indeed they did insert a spy into
the political campaign and I think it is
absolutely unprecedented we've seen you
know we've heard of hints of this kind
of thing back during the the 60s and 70s
right it was not I would argue it's not
nearly as bad and as extensive as this
because among other things these people
are actually going you know they were
actually actively punishing people their
political opponents which is a shock it
is shocking and the amazing part of it
Greg is that you know you've got the
look the Republicans now are looking at
some people whose names we've only heard
a bill pre-snap
he's a guy who was the assistant
director of the FBI counterintelligence
he was struck sports
he helped change the name from you know
gross negligence to extremely careless
and then you've got Michael Steinbach in
John yeah Cologne or whatever whatever
his name is these are people with the
upper echelon of the FBI being called
before Congress do you think they're
gonna take the fifth do you think
they're gonna tell us that what happened
so far they've been obstructing the
Judiciary Committee has for a year been
trying to question people high-ranking
officials of the FBI and the FBI has
been refusing that is obstruction of
Congress it is a classic trope
for people to claim that the FBI cannot
talk about a pending investigation that
is true except for Congress which has a
constitutional duty and a right under a
lawful subpoena to obtain this
information and testimony it's
obstruction of Congress to fail to
comply and the president is right to
demand as chief executive of the
executive branch DOJ and the FBI comply
with the law all right and and tom
Fitton you know i've given you a lot of
credit in the past you have done things
that Congress hasn't been able to do I
mean it's your determination and your
perseverance in trying to get records
under FOIA that has gotten things that
Congress hasn't even been able to get so
you know right now we've got the FBI and
the Department of Justice's Greg says
whose Stonewall they're stonewalling
slow-walking and saying they don't have
records when in fact they do have
records and they have been lying what
does the president do at this point
he is the chief executive the FBI and
Justice Department are under him what
should he do to get this information out
you should order a mandatory
declassification review of the documents
within a reasonable amount of time and
have his lawyers in the White House
counsel's office or some outside experts
that he trusts review these records on
with help Oddie with holdings they
actually want to follow up on to make
sure nothing's being withheld improperly
you know we've got these FOIA cases out
there now I mean we're waiting on the
text messages there's a process now in
court for these various text messages he
could award of the Justice Department
and the FBI start complying with the
transparency law these agencies don't
think they answer to the president and
they don't think the answer to Congress
and I think what they're doing here
judge is they're protecting the Moller
operation which has its origins in all
of us spying and FISA warrants National
Security Letters where they're taking up
the phone records of the campaign on
maskings
and the use of the Clinton DNC dossier
that's all part of mullahs operation now
and that's why they're resisting
Congress because they know if that gets
uncovered so molds operate
you know a town I have been very
critical of the fact that the
Republicans are not doing anything I
mean I'm not being critical of those in
Congress who are doing as much as they
can but it is time to get this thing
rolling it is time for consequences
accountability that's why Donald Trump
is president and so you know I'll go to
you Charlie I mean what do you say to
those people who say oh these are just
more hearings to make the Democrats look
bad or to force these people to testify
to things they don't want to testify to
and that are protected national security
issues they're stalling is what they're
doing they're all stalling and you know
you look back at all the egregious
things I would say call them crimes that
were committed during the campaign and
and after the campaign why did they do
it the reason they did it was such
abandoned was because they thought that
the Hillary Clinton was gonna win the
election and none of this would ever
come to light matter we and of course
what do we do now and and they're doing
the same thing now and they think that
they're going to win control in November
and the Democrats will and they can then
go and cover all of us I think that tom
Fitton is exactly right what they the
president should begin declassifying
everything they should blow everything
out into into and have an absolute
showdown because that you don't you
these people do work for the executive
branch they are answerable to the
legislative branch okay and and and Greg
the final question to you the
significance of struck not testifying is
he cooperating unknown if I were him I'd
cooperate first of all it's always
important to tell the truth and second
of all he can cut himself a deal because
he's in serious legal jeopardy yeah but
you know this is a classic cover-up it's
taking place in Washington they always
claim the mantle of classified
information and then when it's later
unredacted we find out it was a lie and
you know what the problem is Greg and I
have to end here we have an absent
Attorney General and that is a loss to
the American people and the president
anyway thank you gentlemen